Chris !
Sors tes miches de ton lit !
- Salut, ça va ? - Pas pire.
- Et toi ? - Super.
J’ai fait un rêve bizarre, où j’étais caché dans un placard,
- et quelqu’un écoutait de la variété française très fort. - C'est cool.
- On a qui ce matin ? - Monsieur Valentin Simonet, 47 ans.
- Oh non. C'est sa première fois. - Humm... Humm...
Je sais pas bien pourquoi j’ai peur des chiens, en fait.
Et puis vous allez rire, Corinne est éleveuse canine.
Je me demande si ça vient pas de ma mère,
parce qu’elle était tout le temps dans le contrôle et elle avait cette manie...
Pardon.
Léon, tu peux accompagner madame s’il te plait.
Je vous en pris, installez-vous dans le fauteuil.
Ma maitresse de CM2 nous avait raconté l’histoire d’un chien, Toto, et ma mère m’avait...
Alors je vous arrête tout de suite, votre histoire d’oedipe non résolu et votre transfert sur votre prof de maths ça m'intéresse pas du tout.
Je vais juste vous endormir, pénétrer votre cerveau,
trouver le souvenir qui vous traumatise, vous le supprimer et vous réveiller.
Vous signez là ?
Voilà.
Euh, c’est écrit que vous conserver nos souvenirs ?
Oui, absolument.
En fait, nous sommes dans l’obligation légale de conserver vos souvenir effacés et vos data sur un serveur,
au cas où vous souhaiteriez revenir en arrière.
Ah très bien. Bah très bien.
Merci.
Ah, je vois que vous avez choisi Chopin, excellent choix
C'est parti.
A mon avis, ça doit être un traumatisme lié à l'enfance ou à une humiliation.
20 euros sur Roofy.
Ok, et alors moi je t'égalise sur...
“Grosse chienne”. C’est dans le titre.
Et bah non, perdu. Ca c'est à moi.
- Ohla ! Ohla ! Non ! Ca c'est... - C'est absolument pas ça !
Attends.
Non.
Non plus.
Ah ! Beh il a juste été mordu par un Yorkshire quand il était petit.
C'est très décevant.
Bon bah, je supprime et puis je l'éjecte.
Ok.
Tu fais quoi là ?
RIen, je lui supprime son goût pour les pornos qui avilissent les femmes.
Je vais lui installer des goûts sexuels un poil plus progressistes.
- Il nous a pas demandé de faire ça ! - Ca va.
Chris, on a pas le droit !
Qu’est-ce que tu peux être chiant. C'est ouf !
C'est bon je l'ejecte.
Cate vitale, s'il vous plaît.
Merci, ça a été ?
- Merci. - Au revoir.
- Merci beaucoup. - Au revoir.
- Salut. - Merci...
Chris faut que je te parle,
Je sais que Noël c'est un moment un peu compliqué pour toi. Mais, euh...
Cette année...
J'aimerais vraiment essayé de le passer avec ma famille.
D'accord.
Ils me manquent.
Donc je pense que je vais aller à New-York.
- Ca fait hyper longtemps que je les ai pas vu. - D'accord.
Après j'ai pas envie de te laisser toute seule, hein, mais euh...
J'ai vraiment envie d'essayé de reconnecter avec eux.
- Tu comprends ? - D'accord.
Si j’avais encore mes parents, je ferais probablement pareil.
Bah t'as qu'à venir avec moi.
Ouais.
Carrément, bonne idée.
Trop cool !
- Parfait. - Ouais.
Bon allé, je vais me coucher.
- Bonne nuit. - Bonne nuit.